und
wie so ein Agent
diese Katze so verrückt
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es eine Reispfanne und zwar
mit buntem Gemüse mit Rindfleisch ihr
könnt auch Hähnchen oder Shrimps nehmen
oder das ganze auch vegetarisch vegan
zubereiten natürlich wichtig ist dass es
heute einfach eine Reispfanne wird die
in einer Pfanne zubereitet wird das
heißt es ist ein schnelles Abendessen
oder Mittagessen und es soll so ein
bisschen asiatisch angehaucht sein also
wie so ein gebratener Reis den ihr eben
auch beim Asiaten gehen ich muss lachen
Katzen Verständigung gemacht weil Muffin
schon wieder Siri angreift und einfach
nicht aufhört jetzt hat sie wieder ihre
fünf Minuten jetzt hat sie wieder die
Palme ja ich zeige euch mal kurz
die Zutaten ich verwende dafür etwas
Rindfleisch
das sind jetzt
diese Katze ist so verrückt guck sie dir
an
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
diese sich entlang schiebt am Boden
wie so ein Agent
diese Katze so verrückt dafür nehme ich
Rindfleisch Pak Choi Frühlingszwiebeln
Edamame die sind aus dem Tiefkühlfach
roten Spitzpaprika zum Anbraten Kokosöl
etwas Ingwer eine rote Zwiebel ich habe
ich etwas Currypaste zum Abschmecken
Sojasoße Kokosmilch und hier habe ich
etwas Wasser Reis das ist ein paar
beutreis Erdnüsse und bambusbrüstlinge
das sind jetzt Zutaten die wir da hatten
wir dazu gekauft weil es einfach perfekt
dazu passt ansonsten nehmt ihr einfach
Gemüse was ihr im Kühlschrank oder
Tiefkühlfach habt es passt alles das ist
jetzt quasi wieder so ein Grundrezept
und ihr haut alles mit rein was ihr eben
noch so habt
ich habe jetzt hier hatte ich einen
Roastbeef das habe ich jetzt ein
bisschen zerschnitten und kann auch
schon mal mein Kokosöl in der Pfanne
erhitzen damit ich hier das Fleisch
schön anbraten kann die Paprika in
schöne feine Stücke schneiden den
packzeug gebe ich ganz am Ende mit dazu
alles im mundgerechte Stücke schneiden
das ist glaube das ist wichtigste
sobald die Pfanne heiß ist könnt ihr
dann auch das Fleisch wirklich rundherum
ganz scharf anbraten
die sind auch nicht gar die sind innen
noch rot aber die ziehen dann später
nach und wenn ihr es ganz perfekt machen
wollt lasst ihr das Rindfleisch vorher
auch ein bisschen bei Raumtemperatur
stehen damit es nicht mehr ganz so kalt
ist aus dem Kühlschrank
da hacke ich jetzt kurz die Zwiebel fein
und Bratze mit dem Ingwer an
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kurz anbraten
[Musik]
dann mit Wasser aufgießen
Sojasauce dazu
und jetzt gebt ihr auch direkt den Reis
mit rein den habe ich schon gewaschen
jeder mal kommt auch mit rein die
Bambussprossen und jetzt gießt ihr noch
die Kokosmilch dazu
und dann darf das ganze erstmal
aufkochen
also wieder Herd hochschalten
und ich mache Reisgerichte immer ganz
gerne im gusseisentopf egal ob jetzt in
der Gusseisen Pfanne oder im großen Topf
denn ich kann da das Ganze aufkochen
lassen den Deckel dann drauf geben und
dann wirklich bei ganz niedriger Stufe
weiter köcheln für etwa vier bis fünf
Minuten und dann kann man eigentlich
auch den Herd schon ausschalten denn der
Gusseisen Topf ist so warm dass er
wirklich oder das dadurch der Reis
einfach schön weiter ziehen kann ohne
dass man eben weiterhin Strom braucht
also das kann man auch ganz gut immer
zum Strom sparen nehmen tatsächlich weil
er eben die Hitze ganz gut hält am
besten auch immer den Deckel drauf geben
wenn ihr was aufkochen lassen wollt aber
aufpassen dass es euch nicht überkocht
hier nämlich jetzt den Pack Joy und die
Frühlingszwiebeln die habe ich noch ein
bisschen grob den vorderen Bereich gebe
ich mit der Paprika rein und die
hinteren Blätter die gebe ich ganz zum
Schluss mit rein
sobald hier der Reis kocht gebe ich
jetzt Paprika und Pak Choi Stile dazu
und gern schon mal mit Salz und Pfeffer
abschmecken
und jetzt Deckel drauf und bei mittlerer
Stufe etwa 5 Minuten köcheln lassen dann
den Herd ausschalten und einfach gar
ziehen lassen
also je nachdem welche Reissorte ihr
natürlich verwendet aber das kann man ja
gleich ein bisschen austesten
das sieht so gut aus
ja jetzt ist der Moment ich schalte den
Herd aus
rühre alles noch mal gut durch
und jetzt kommen hier noch die
restlichen Zutaten rein das heißt das
packt Scheu mit den Frühlingszwiebeln
[Musik]
ich habe eine asiatische Pfanne gemacht
und hier das drin Fleisch könnt jetzt
noch ein bisschen mit Salz und Pfeffer
würzen
hast du Hunger
und das gebe ich jetzt auch noch mit
rein
ja ich hoffe doch
kurz einrühren und dann zieht es noch so
ein bisschen nach und ist in der Mitte
noch schöne rosa ihr könnt natürlich
auch ganz durchbraten oder noch ein
bisschen früher mit in die Pfanne geben
und dann ist das perfekt komm wir
probieren jetzt ja
dann noch Erdnüsse drauf geben
ich richte euch gleich noch einen
schönen Teller an und jetzt probieren
wir mal
aber probier ruhig auch mal mit der
restwanne
[Musik]
schmeckt total lecker und frisch ein
bisschen scharf ein bisschen wegen der
Curry
ist gut
ich lasse es noch ein bisschen ziehen
aber
es ist jetzt schon wahnsinnig lecker
probiert es also gerne aus ich hoffe
euch gefällt das Rezept und dann sehen
wir uns wieder am Sonntag mit einem
schönen süßen Rezept macht's gut
[Musik]